more than 300 000 children in England
have to share beds with family members
because of overcrowding a study by the
National Housing Foundation found that
one in six children are living in
cramped conditions because their
families cannot afford a suitable home
we're joined by the director of policy
and research at the National Housing
Federation Alistair Smith also good to
see you this morning and walk us through
the figures because and this is
happening so often these days this
morning whilst I was going through this
story I was stopped in my tracks I mean
there is a real significant problem at
the moment isn't there well yes that's
right and every child in this country
deserves to have access to a good
quality and safe home where they have
the space to live and to grow but this
research shows that unfortunately for
too many children that's just not the
case so two million children that's one
in six of you said as you've said are
living in overcrowded accommodation and
more than 300 000 actually having to
share a bed then with another family
member and we're also seeing that around
a quarter of adults not being able to
actually sleep at night in a bedroom but
instead having to sleep say perhaps in
the hallway or in the kitchen or even in
the bathroom so really disturbing
figures I think for some people that
this will appear to be a stupid question
but just just articulate the problems
that arise from people living in
conditions like this from from having to
share beds in this fashion absolutely so
the impact of overcrowding on households
is is quite profound and there are a
number of them so the people that took
part in this research they said that
their mental and physical health had
been negatively affected by this for
children in particular around half of
those living in overcrowded homes said
that they felt embarrassed or ashamed
even to bring friends back to their
house so that has an impact on their
relationships also that they didn't have
enough space to do their homework so it
affects their educational outcomes and
you can imagine that for a large family
without enough space that pressure of
just living in a confined space means
worse family Dynamics so simply more
arguments or perhaps parents who are
unable to get along as well as they
might because they don't have the space
to do so is this a problem that existed
during that covered period when we were
in lockdowns or is it something that has
been exacerbated by that I'm just
wondering about you know spending excuse
me month after month of lockdown in such
cramp conditions having to share beds in
that fashion so how an issue was it
during that that period I think what we
saw during that period in the pandemic
is this issue manifesting itself even
more because the more people just simply
having to spend time in their own homes
but actually this issue is is
long-standing and it's caused by around
four Decades of under investment in
social housing the biggest cause of
overcrowding in homes is a lack of
supply of social homes so we've seen
that by successive governments over four
decades and in particular just over a
decade ago the government made a
decision to cut Capital funding for new
social housing by 63 and that means that
last year we only built around six and a
half thousand homes for social rent
that's the most affordable tenure of
their home that would be most suitable
for people in overcrowded homes on Lower
incomes and that's a drop of 80 percent
but research that we can we
co-commissioned at the National Housing
Federation a few years ago shows that in
fact to meet housing need in full we
should be building 90 000 homes for
social rent every year for a decade so
we're a huge huge way away from that how
easy would it be for the Housing
Industry to scale up the product of new
housing particularly social housing and
I so often see new developments around
here in London advertising themselves as
having a affordable housing contained
within you know I mean I don't know what
their definition of affordable is but
it's certainly nowhere close to mine
absolutely so uh no one's going to
pretend it's it's a straightforward
issue
um but that's why we at the National
Housing Federation are calling on the
government to set out its plans in a
long-term plan for how it's going to
solve the housing crisis and we strongly
believe that as part of that long-term
plan they need to make a commitment to
significantly invest in building new
social homes year on year as I said at
least 90 000 homes for social rent every
year for a decade to meet housing need
in full and then only then would we see
the issues around overcrowding and other
housing related problems uh then start
to go away just briefly I mean is there
a rule perhaps for housing associations
for sorry for the private sector to
really go health or leather in terms of
social housing and is there a market
that they could take advantage of
so um for us at the National Housing
Federation we represent housing
associations our members are already
doing as much as they can to help
contribute to solving the housing crisis
in fact building across a range of 10
years about 50 000 homes a year
um what we need to do is build more
social homes and we believe uh that of
course the private sector has a role to
play in that and we will work in
partnership with them on that but we
believe fundamentally housing
associations are best placed as
not-for-profit landlords who are driven
by a social purpose this is after what
we were set up to do what we exist to do
is to provide housing to those that need
it at a price that they can afford We
Believe Housing Association is the best
place to do that Alistair good to talk
to you this morning thanks for being
with us